[Musique]
et elle m'a rejoint en plateau mélanie
poquet bonsoir en ces temps hivernaux
pas toujours facile de profiter de
l'extérieur c'est aussi l'occasion de se
rendre dans les salles culturelles de
l'agglomération alors chaque week-end de
nombreux rendez-vous sont ne sont pas
pas manquer à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
mélanie poquet pour votre coup de coeur
de la semaine vous avez sélectionné deux
sorties si vous voulez être époustouflé
des portés acrobatiques et des envolées
pyramidale direction le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la scène
nationale accueille la compagnie xy
alors il n'est pas encore minuit c'est
le nom de ses créations imaginées 22
acrobates qui se porte qui voltigent des
duos des quatuors qu'ils se font se
défont sans cesse il n'est pas encore
minuit s'interroge notamment sur le
rapport du groupe au vivre ensemble
[Musique]
m
et la compagnie fait trois
représentations sur la scène nationale
le spectacle est à voir en famille dès
l'âge de 8 ans au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on va à s'émerveiller mélanie à
elancourt le public va rigoler oui il
est jeune il est belge et chaque soir il
fait rire ses auditeurs avec sa
compatriote charline van acker et son
journal sur france inter alors alex
vizorek sera sur la scène du prisme à
elancourt ce samedi pas de brèves ce
soir là mais un décryptage de l'art alex
vizorek est une oeuvre d'art où vont se
côtoyer bergson rostropovitch et pamela
anderson
le public va pouvoir découvrir une autre
facette de l'humoriste c'est comme la
politique c'est pas parce qu'on n'y
comprend rien qu'on ne peut pas en fait
ça va dit mme morano l'a bien compris
lequel des deux est un tableau fauviste
ya un piège sachez que malick il n'était
pas hyper content de son travail
non mais et pourtant il n'avait pas
dépassé les spectacles ce soir on va
parfois apprendre des choses
et puis de temps en temps une petite
blague de culte pour récupérer double
loyer alors ce sont deux sur deux idées
de spectacles parmi tant d'autres bien
d'autres rendez vous se passe aussi ce
week-end pour être sûr de ne rien rater
grégory rendez vous sur le site du
casque ou dans l'émission le 7-8 culture
votre émission mélanie a retrouvé dans
un instant sur tv 78